breaking news out of Libya right now
there are reports that a new rocket
attack has been carried out on motika
Airport and the capital Tripoli his
undershirt a civilian plane belonging to
Libyan Airlines was hit as a result of
this is go to the capital now Tripoli
and bring in our machmood abdulahad who
is joining us live so I mean obviously
my murder there have been calls for some
sort of ceasefire particularly since
it's been - pandemic has hit that's
obviously not happening in Libya so what
do you know television it there you know
have been targeting an idea intercourse
past few hours with thousands of rockets
we've seen smoke coming out of MIT
buildings on file and were killing
reports for the definitive movie about
civilians families in panic going out in
the streets in a state of shock state of
panic
and some reports from a nigeria airport
suggest that there is a civilian plane
is set on fire dude i you know michelle
that this Airport Narita Airport is the
only operational airport in a capital
city and it has been the target of
hostile forces rockets and even air
strikes since the they launched it the
military campaign to take control of
trickery in April last year have two
sources say that there is a drone
launcher in that Airport used by Turkish
drones to target Haskell's forces
locations in southern Tripoli and many
other locations including the central
Libya and also in in the West especially
a woodsy air air base as you know we
share that were GNP is about 100
typically
kilometers in the western south of
Tripoli has been at the hub of Haskins
force again it has been also used by
hackers was to launch airstrikes to
target the government forces locations
inexorably Tripoli the question is
whether the person would respond to the
international calls to de-escalate and
restrain from targeting civilian areas
as you know that this mighty gear code
is at the heart of civilian area
residential area the many many tablets
are now out in the streets in a state of
panic of thousands of grad rockets
launched it by half disposal are
targeted a nineteen year airport you
know that after sources have not been
responding to the calls from the United
Nations support mission yeah helping
statement condemning the attacks on
civilians and civilian facilities and
residential areas also even from the
United Nations the spokesman of the
United Nations Secretary Panetta
skeptical Secretary General Steve and DJ
week has been also calling on the
warring parties to refrain from talking
civilian facilities but it seems that
hospice was not responding there only
two four hours ago they wanted a
diplomatic neighborhood in Tripoli were
of embassies the Turkish embassy the
Italian embassy and also other a
diplomatic mission headquarters killing
three people and wounding several others
wish it all right Montel we'll have with
the latest about what's happening there
at the motika Airport thank you